let's talk about Trump's approval rating
in the midst of the indictment of former
Trump campaign manager and chairman Pao
manna Ford and his associate Rick gates
and the indictment and guilty plea of
George papadopolis Donald Trump's
approval rating has hit another
presidency low and those numbers that
data doesn't yet even account for the
indictments and we'll talk about whether
the indictments will impact Trump's
approval rating so first and foremost
let's start with the NBC Washington Wall
Street Journal poll in that poll Donald
Trump's approval rating is down to 38
percent now why is that relevant well
it's relevant because in that NBC
news/wall Street Journal poll Trump has
never had a 38 percent approval that is
a poll low for the NBC Wall Street
Journal poll but you might say to me
well hold on a second David 38% isn't
that low and anyway what if I don't care
about the NBC Wall Street Journal poll
there are other polls I am glad you
asked let's go to Old Faithful the
Gallup approval poll the gold standard
of presidential approval based on a
three-day rolling average and they've
been doing it for decades it's been
something like 40 years
Trump has hit another new low there
Trump has hit a record low for his
presidency look at that cliff looks ugly
very ugly of 33% his previous low and if
you go back and look I don't remember if
it was in late August or where exactly
the 34% showed up on the Gallup approval
poll now 33 percent approval for Donald
Trump a presidency low here's something
interesting
we now are getting into uncharted
territory
uncharted lows for Trump compared to
other presidents let's put up on the
screen how long it took other presidents
in their presidencies to reach a low of
33 percent approval and you'll notice
that Ronald Reagan never had an approval
rating as low as 33 percent Bill Clinton
never had an approval rating as low as
33 percent Barack Obama never had a 33
percent approval rating George HW Bush
so
over 1200 days before he hit 33% and
george w bush who dealt with 9/11 took
1933 days to ever see a 33 percent
approval rating I do not believe that
the indictments are going to impact
donald trump's approval in any
significant way they are still for now
the Trump team is doing a good enough
job of convincing the people that still
support them that these indictments
don't yet implicate Donald Trump
remember if you're not in the 33% or 35%
that approves if the job Trump is doing
you already disapprove and so the
indictments aren't going to make a
difference if you still are in the 33 or
35 or 37 percent that approve of the job
that Donald Trump is doing I think that
you at some level are so ideologically
committed and are experiencing such
cognitive dissonance when it comes to
Trump that for now you're not going to
be impacted by these indictments and by
the way we're also at the point where
Trump's stupid statement that time about
I could shoot people on Fifth Avenue and
people would still support me I think
that unless Trump does actually shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue or video is
released of Trump raping someone right
like something completely undeniable and
depraved and completely heinous I think
that the 33 percent which might be the
number that support Donald Trump at this
point at least according to Gallup I
don't know that anything is going to
change their mind at this point because
really it should be zero right I mean
I've had some interesting conversations
I was recently in Arizona and Las Vegas
over the last month and they're way more
trumpets there than here in Boston
Massachusetts and I had different
trumpets talk to me and I would say to
them what has Trump done that you really
like in other words what do you see as
the policies or actions that Trump has
taken that are good for you and it's a
combination of totally horrific and
depraved and absolutely unintelligible
for example someone said to me I really
like what he's done with the economy
well what exactly has he done well we've
had this stock market run up yeah we
have it's unclear how much it has to do
with Donald Trump and we also appear to
be
in a major major bubble but what about
something else he's done these crony
capitalist deals with companies like
carrier he's proposed a huge deficit
exploding tax plan so if you still
support Donald Trump explain to me
exactly call in during live calls call
in say David I am a Trump supporter and
I want to tell you what he has done to
gain my approval I would love to hear
from some of these people because I've
never heard a good defense of what
exactly is Trump doing that is an actual
accomplishment that you think warrants
or has earned your approval you can also
discuss it with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership